unlv is graduating its winter class of  2021 about 2 200 students from 37 states  and 45 countries are set to turn their  tassels the ceremony is underway as we  speak over at the thomas and mack center  and one of those graduates walking in a  cap and gown today is a little younger  than the rest last month we introduced  you to 15 year old jack rico the young  scholar skipped junior in high school  and jumped straight into junior college  when he was just 13 years old he  transferred to unlv and he tells us he  is excited for the future  i feel pretty i'm like  very like excited you know i mean i'm  it's the end of a long journey and  just kind of like seeing it close it's  like i'm very excited  very exciting stuff all right rico  graduates with honors and a bachelor's  degree in history he says he is not sure  what comes next but is considering a  career in real estate computer science  or maybe film